ان نتابع معكم هذه الصور الحيه والصور
المباشره اذا نتابع هذه الصور للوقفات
الاحتجاجيه التي نشاهدها الان على الهواء
مباشره لانصار الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب
بعد توجيه المحكمه في منهات اربعه وثلاثين
تهمه تتعلق
بشراء صمت ممثله اباحيه بطبيعه الحال تحدث
انه بريء ونفى هذه التهم الموجهه له اذا
نتابع معكم سنكون معكم لحظه بلحظه في هذه
التغطيه الحيه والمباشره والتي بدات منذ
مغادره الرئيس ترامب من فلوريدا والعوده
اليها قبل قليل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
نعم وكانت محكمه من هاتن الجنائيه من احد
الرئيس الامريكي السابق دونالد ترامب
اطلاق سراح غير مشروط وكانت رامب نفى ان
يكون مذنبا في اربعه وثلاثين اتهاما تم
توجيههم اليه من قاضي وذلك بعد ان رفعت
المحكمه في منهات السريه عن لائحه اتهام
ترامب واتهم مدعي عام منهاتن ترامب
بالتامر كما نفى الرئيس الامريكي السابق
تقديم ريشن لشراء سكوتي امراتين ايضا
تزوير سجلاته التجاريه قبل انتخابات العام